great thank you very much you're gonna
love this next piece you're gonna love
this because this is
right up the alley that you are just
traveling on take it away so the
pandemic which has us spending
a lot more time at home has also
discovered has also led to the discovery
of new hobbies
including the art of mixology that's
what i've been up to banknote
to appreciate the complexity of a
well-made cocktail you have to go back
in time to understand its roots
and as we discovered those roots lie in
medicine
mystery and mischief i know i've got
your attention
we visited a distillery in brooklyn
whose recipes draw from centuries old
tonics
including some that date back to the
black plague
so this is where the magic happens
we met 4th ave spirits co-founders aaron
fox and daniel delanoes in their
brooklyn distillery
what they call their laboratory where
they test and produce a variety of
botanical spirits
and over here we've got infusions of
peaches and
ground cherries infusion is a word you
hear a lot around here
as the duo experiments with fruits
berries roots
plants and flowers to create
one-of-a-kind liquors
and spirits the idea to start those
experiments came about
eight years ago over an after dinner
drink dad was kind of like well
and how are these things made and i was
kind of like
i don't know there's a lot of mystery
around it a lot of secrecy
so i said you know it'd be fun to to
experiment and
i jumped up from the table and was like
let's do it let's do it
let's do it and so began their journey
to unravel some of those mysteries
starting with understanding the history
of herbal medicine's role in modern day
spirits
omari and aparitv and these types of
drinks were
created by monks in in the middle ages
to go into
what was then a pharmacy this would be a
cure-all for this this would be a cure
for that
in their modern day medicine cabinet of
spirits an amaro they call
marseille the bitter liqueur is often
used as a centerpiece of before
and after dinner cocktails the aperitif
and the digestive
are very specific i think the
interesting thing is that you know
with the detoxivo going from herbal
medicine
going into culinary culture is that it
does help you digest physiologically
the apparativo the one you have before
dinner
does the same it'll make you hungry it
brings on the appetite
people would have been drinking it in
marseilles specifically yeah and in
toulouse as well and
and not as an enjoyable thing really as
a you know as
a medicinal as a medicinal thing yeah so
it's later where you know
in our case we take out the vinegar and
take out the garlic its recipe
is rooted in medieval legend as the
bubonic plague ravaged france
four thieves who were believed to have
concocted a cure for the disease
were caught stealing from victims they'd
be punished
unless they shared their secret recipe
known as
vinegar of four thieves or marseille
wine
there's a historical figure named
richard forthave
it's quite possible that it was that it
was his concoction
that through you know kind of the
telling and retelling became
four thieves instead of fourth a of his
name
fourth ave a 15th century doctor is the
namesake of their company
and its logo a plague mask hand drawn by
aaron
illustrates a familiar sight from a much
different time
in the history of that the mask that's
on the
the front of our label of the the mro
named after marseille
and that being this kind of one of the
earliest uses of masks that are now
you know that we're wearing right now
that we're wearing now and i see all
over and that was
this was a kind of long mask kind of
shaped a bit like a bird's beak and
would have been
stuffed with different botanicals the
plague doctors would get the oils
on their skin which would repel fleas
intakes
sourcing their ingredients from
centuries ago fourth ave is just one of
many distilleries of late
capitalizing on the craft cocktail trend
what do you think of the trend
that perhaps first started with food
where people are looking for fresh
ingredients there's a movement to
farm-to-table ingredients that now we're
seeing
a bit of that trend with cocktails when
the economic crash of 2008 hit
we saw cocktail um creativity explode
and probably with this recession we're
already seeing
online this whole new you know canned
cocktail
beverages um this whole new economy
bloom
rachel meyer is a botanist and assistant
professor at university of california
santa cruz
she's also the co-author of the book
botany at the bar
it's part of like just being human we've
always had
competitive feasting where we're always
looking for the coolest weirdest
wackiest
most delicious thing to be able to show
off to our friends
and sometimes our foes and yet often
what's old
is new again so this is a bottle that
wouldn't be sold at a liquor shop or a
wine shop
you would find it at an apothecary this
is sort of like a library
yeah what we want to do with 4tha was
really make
you know age-worthy spirits and
hopefully in 40 years
people will be out collecting this
you were asking me how i came across the
story i was intrigued when i saw a
bottle of fourth day with the plague
mask
given that we are in the midst of a
pandemic i thought that was really
interesting and when we started
researching my producer vida and i we
realized that they came up with this
concoction
that was based on a medicine from the
15th century wow cool
that's so amazing and i've seen all of
your mixology so a lot of those photos
were
my cocktail creations exactly stuck in
lockdown that's what i was doing by the
way
a couple people have already sipped
coquito
happy new year everybody happy new year
indeed